.
NFIDEN PRODUCT.
>> FORMEDONALD LIAR DEFENSEATR
SEARCHED HIS
HOAS
TRUMP SO
THS ACTIONUSSLF NGE BEPLARGUD TH
O
HAVE A BASIS IN
NI JNO
IT'S F
WHERE YOU KI WHAT WE OUTAY
SOHILIAR ING F D THAT THE FBI V.
S LAWYEEEVE N FLOATING THAIDEA.N
THEORY.I KOTED AONOX.
DOCUMENT WAND TRUMP'S D OKHATEVE
COUL
THEN WE HAD PEOPLERIGHT T ON THI
RACY THEORY
GO.SIGNED THWARTM EXPOSING T
NOF  HHA A
OP>>OUR PIECE ALSO
HIMSELFTHIR
E REALLY ISN'TN FOR WHAT HAPPED?
>> THERE
ANUTISM,
PEHO AREFA JYING WHAT THIS, WHA.
DOCUMER S TO CHICAGO.ST BARACKS3
TRUMP  M MANY
THAT COMPELLED THE NIOL
ARCHIVES AND RECORNISTRATION TO
A STATEM
HEIO
YSICAL O
THEY ARE THE O0 CORDS O THEIOWN
INFOIOAT CLASSIFIESENTANOTHETY I